- Don't cough it'll fall over.
- [Woman] Okay.
- Watch out.
(clatters)
(upbeat music)
(whooshes and squeaks)
- We've been dating for,
I want to say three and a half years now.
- Yeah, going on four.
- Like six month, I think, almost,
- Almost seven but like who's counting.
- We've been dating
- For like nine months.
- Sure.
- Today we are building a
- [Both] Desk.
- I've never built furniture period.
- We've built a lot of furniture together.
- I'm not handy at all.
- I've no building skills.
- I'm already trying to manage.
- Do we get instructions?
- Oh it's missing like
all of the inside of it.
- That's not fair.
- Oh my god.
- Oh.
- It goes from two to 39, page 39.
(laughs)
- I thought that was just
like a joke in the beginning.
- I trust her guys but I
don't know if she can do it
in 30 minutes so.
- Yeah.
- We're gonna see.
- Alright, alright.
- So what does a desk look like?
- We know what it's supposed to look like,
so I think we should just put
the boards in that position.
Step one,
- That's the top that's step one.
- The lack of instructions is
really killing me right now.
- Might as well just go
completely outside the box.
- I'm really lost.
- Really?
Making me lose my confidence.
- [Shakeya] This is harder than I thought.
- I got so excited.
- These things
- Stick in the thing thing.
- There's tow holes
here, and two holes here.
- [Omar] Whoa.
- It doesn't match anything.
So like lost.
- Wait do they match up?
Absolutely not.
- This is stressful.
- For how to be in a relationship.
- Okay we have to just talk through.
- I feel like I'm at that point now,
that if I don't get more
information I'm stumped.
- Sweet, sweet, sweet.
- Wow.
- We've earned another page.
- Oh thanks.
- Sweet.
- Halfway through,
- Oh my god it's still missing, oh my god.
- It's cool, that's all I
need just get me started.
- Okay, they is direction one.
- She's doing the bigger drawer,
I'm doing the smaller drawer.
- She's way better at
understanding the directions,
whereas I am better at
actually doing them.
- Everyone has like stresses
within their relationship,
if you're with the right
person then you guys can help
each other with those problem.
- Yeah.
- So that's why I think
we work well together.
- Or we could work on the frame,
could function as a desk if needed.
Like are you gonna get to this?
- This is our problem in
life, you really need to like
prioritize one thing at a time.
- I've just walked away.
- Oh yeah, normally I'm just sitting there
for the rest of the night
building the furniture.
- I come back in a little
bit with a glass of wine
and then take a breather and I come back.
And then I'll, I'll keep helping.
- [Rebecca] I would
have broken up with him,
I wouldn't have went on a second date.
I'd have been like he doesn't
know how to do a damn thing
and neither do I, this is horrible.
(laughs)
- Oh my gosh.
- This is great.
- Forget this.
- Okay Ange, I'm gonna give
you instructions really quickly
and you're gonna have
to pay attention to me.
- Okay,
look at it, I made the desk.
- No, that's not gonna hold it.
- By the time you gave us the instructions
we were already doing stuff,
so why not just keep doing that stuff?
- [Shakeya] We can do this, come on Jade.
- You can hop on something else.
- [Omar] You make a bad
decision, you continue making it.
You don't give up halfway.
- See how she just leaves me
with half, half in the wind.
- No I was trying to grab.
- Half a screw in half a screw out.
- [Ange] You can pay people
to do these things for you.
- Building a desk you half to communicate
like you have to communicate
and a lot of times
like you have to work together.
- We're gonna get a thing that stands.
That has two legs.
- Supposed to have three legs.
- Yeah whatever.
- You should never do it with your hand,
you just wanna do it
with your screwdriver.
- We're gonna stand this bad boy up.
- No that's not what goes there.
- Could you see how just
now I'm like, she's like,
you gotta put a start it
off with the screwdriver
and I'm like no I want to put
it in with my hands first.
And she's like no use a
screwdriver, like, yeah.
(laughs)
Yeah, like.
- There, help me make this stand,
I don't want to embarrass
myself that much.
Oh shit, shit.
- Oh no.
come on, you got it.
- Shit.
- See she's a perfectionist,
she's really putting in every screw.
- We have the directions.
(blows raspberries)
There's really something wrong with us.
- Man if we were moving like this
when we first got this desk,
- We would have been done.
- We're not like other couples.
We're a stupid couple.
- Bring it on down.
It's gonna smash my finger.
- Where's the (whirs)
- How we used to play legos when as a kid,
this is what I feel
like I'm dig right now.
(clatters)
- I believe in you.
I was like we got to build it up.
Like we have one minute.
- This is called minimalism,
I don't know if you've heard of it.
- Just pelvic thrust it together.
- Okay, one, two, three, go.
- [Rebecca] I like took the time run out,
- Look though, we're just
like alternative winning.
(laughs)
- Okay.
- Nice.
(Camptown Races)
- We built a desk.
- I don't think it deserves a high five.
- Next time you go on a
date, make sure you have
an instruction manual.
- 30 minutes was definitely difficult.
- It does compare to relationships,
you're not given a book
or instructions on how
to love someone or how to be with someone.
- Sometimes you have to
make do with what you have.
- It really does represent
our relationship.
- In how it's barely being held together
and how okay we are with it.
We make it work.
- This is my best friend
so doing anything together
is always fun, as long as we communicate
like I said before, we get along,
then it's cool.